[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toujours un moment que ça part en vrille
dans les mariages
donc moi j'ai qu'une hâte c'est de voir
la mariée en train de pleurer de hurler
sur ses orgies de fait à ce qu'on peut
les mariages dans la vie c'est pas comme
on l'a fait demain je sais vraiment pas
plutôt bien chiant hall avec des vieux
matière d'ailleurs il est où mon mec il
faut retrouver de plus belles femmes de
ces bois
[Musique]
chez moi je vais largué mathieu
maintenant aujourd'hui je demande leur
mariage
[Musique]
être adulte c'est aussi savoir prendre
une décision on est nul et même pas
capable d'aller parler à quelqu'un moi
je vais l'avoir maintenant la phase i
mais ceci si la cij a dit je vais
prendre un énorme bateau pas du tout et
c'est je vais parler maintenant ok bon
bah moi j'attends que le mariage partent
en vrille
comme ça je profite de l'engueulade
général et hop mais mes roses
je te présente mon copain ici toi et
s'appelle comment ce charmant jeune
homme je m'appelle norman et vous êtes
une petite amie de ma petite fille
ah ouais je suis le petit copain de
marivent à oui ça c'est une belle
demande en mariage rien avec la bague à
coucher de soleil demande au mariage
avec eux tu vas me demande en mariage
le rythme de jeu blessé
je croyais que tu voulais pas te marier
je veux te faire la surprise je vais
faire une demande super romantique et
voilà c'est loupé je n'en ai pas raté
on voit là tu vois je suis posé en
couple comme s'il voulait on s'aime on
s'aime tellement c'est clairement la
femme de ma vie j'y pense
bon il ya des hauts et des bas de se
marier un jour qui sait peut-être
peut-être pas peut-être que oui
peut-être que non
[Musique]
moi c'est bon c'est pas les rejoindre
tes potes halldor merci à d'abord je
vais jusqu'au bout c'est vraiment sympa
je comprends un peu envie de venir à mal
tout seul super chiant tu sais je m'en
fous j'ai très bien tout seul mais bon
ça sur les vieux alors je fige et m'ont
procuré matin at-on plan cul bah moi
c'est pareil moi j'ai aussi un plan qe2
3 profite bien bon ça lui ciao
ouais ouais c'est parfait vas-y fais
quoi à oui oui tu en as trop bien ici
ok ça marche et le oui est ce que tu
veux me alors allo allo ça capte la
balle à la barre d'accord merci monsieur
à l'eau fait le ring je n'ai pas envie
mon frère et moi non plus
reda les jeux peut tout expliquer en
train de me trouver là ça veut dire
qu'on est plus ensemble je te présente
françoise voilà c'est pas juste un plan
cul je l'aimais ça fait plusieurs mois
qu'on se voit en secret si ça fait
plusieurs mois
l'amour est le plus fort ça va moi je
t'aime et ses plus importants non mais
moi aussi je t'aime et tu n'as pas
besoin d'eux pour vos autres qu'on a un
vrai couple on sait on sait voilà on
peut faire plein d'autres trucs on peut
voyager on peut habiter ensemble ample
mais je sais bien mais on verra ça plus
tard j'aimerais bien car il on verra ça
moi aussi
non
moi
allez
là c'est un truc de fou depuis le temps
est sec oise 1 s'est fiancé ou quoi non
j'ai dit non oui moi aussi
oui mais le mais quand même ça ça coûte
une blinde ce truc là vous avez raison
il faut faire ce qu'on veut qu'on fasse
et parce qu'on veut que les gens veulent
qu'on obtient la plus radicale c'était
un super mariage on trinque à l'est
rigobert marie répond quoi
[Musique]